you guys are truly going to be disgusted
by what i'm going to tell you today
last week i already told you that we
have been
100 demonetized on facebook
we are making 0.0 on facebook
because i talked about the fact
that former trump adviser steve bannon
right wingnut
suggested dr fauci be beheaded okay
we didn't show any gory videos we called
him
out for saying it we called out the
violent rhetoric from the right against
doctors
we were reporting on it and we were 100
demonetized on facebook our entire
channel we've come to build our facebook
revenue
it's about 17 18 percent of our monthly
revenue
it's gone okay i told you that last week
that's already bad enough
and the right loves to say oh the social
platforms are
all left wing they oppress the right
and they favor the left and blah blah
blah but we are
banned from monetizing every video on
facebook because i mentioned what steve
bannon said okay
here's the new wrinkle mark zuckerberg
has decided
facebook won't be banning steve bannon
because of that video that he posted
because he hasn't done
anything bad enough to be bandworthy
reuters
reports zuckerberg defends not
suspending ex-trump aide bannon from
facebook
and it goes on to say that facebook
chief executive mark zuckerberg
said on thursday trump white house
adviser former trump white house adviser
steve bannon
didn't violate enough of their policies
to suspend him from facebook
when he urged the beheading of two
senior u.s officials
i really need everybody to understand
this what steve bannon said about dr
fauci is supposedly so bad so
vile so horrible so toxic that
i was 100 demonetized for mentioning
bannon said this and it's bad but the
person who actually
said the horrible vile thing for which i
was demonetized
he didn't do anything worthy of being
banned from facebook
facebook which republicans love to hate
and like all major social media networks
they claim
facebook favors the left facebook hates
the right
they ended my monetization for
criticizing what steve bannon said
but mark zuckerberg says the guy who
said it
nah he didn't do anything ban worthy
give me a break come on guys
it's almost satirical that it's so
absurd
update on monetization is we are still
as of this moment 100 percent
demonetized
some people wrote to me saying they have
contacts at facebook uh they have some
emails in
others said david monetization might
return automatically after a week or
potentially 30 days
i will let you know in any case we this
is why we are working on building
direct support so we're not knocked
around by this stuff
grab a membership at joinpakman.com we
have this coupon code
fresh start saves you 70 percent
and every membership protects us from
this type of nonsense
so uh please do grab a membership at
joinpakman.com
and i will certainly let you know if
facebook monetization
ever returns